Hello I’m Daven Hiskey, you are watching
the Today I Found Out YouTube channel.
In the video today, we’re looking at how
fluorescent light bulbs work and why they
buzz.
Comprised of a sealed tube coated on the inside
with a phosphor powder and usually filled
with argon and a tiny bit of mercury, the
way in which fluorescent bulbs produce light
is extremely fascinating.
While the underlying physical mechanisms in
the fixture and bulb can vary a bit in design,
in a nutshell a fluorescent light works via
two electrodes at either end of the tube emitting
electrons as they heat up.
Eventually, an arc is created (via varying
mechanisms depending on the fixture and bulb
design) with the electrons shooting across
the bulb through the ionized gas from one
electrode to the other; as they move through
the tube, the tiny bit of mercury in the bulb
is vaporized and as the electrons collide
with its atoms, it excites the electrons in
the atoms to higher energy levels.
However, this higher energy level is unstable
and post-collision, as the electrons rapidly
return to their original energy level, they
release photons, albeit mostly ultraviolet
(UV) light that we humans cannot see.
Not a very useful light source at this point!
The photons in the UV light, however, in turn
excite the electrons in the phosphor that
is coating the bulb, similarly causing them
to move away from their nuclei to a higher
state; the phosphor electrons then quickly
return to their original state, at which point
they also release energy in the form of photons,
but this time mostly in the human visible
spectrum, creating the bulk of the visible
light that makes these bulbs useful in office
buildings the world over.
Now to the buzzing- Absent preventative measures,
the current in the fluorescent tube would
rise to dangerous levels owing to the fact
that the electrical resistance of the ionized
gas in the tube drops progressively as it
heats up.
So without something put in place to stop
the current rising too much, this would be
a cascading problem.
Eventually, it could well flip your circuit
breaker or the bulb could explode.
Whatever the case, your lights would quickly
stop working.
To manage that, fluorescent bulb fixtures
are equipped with a ballast of some sort.
This ballast classically comes in the form
of an iron core wrapped in copper wire.
The result is a device that slows the current's
growth, keeping it at a safe level for the
bulb to operate efficiently.
Important to the discussion of buzzing is
that the electricity energizes the ballast
into producing a magnetic field.
This is, in fact, how this type of ballast
works in the first place- as more current
is passed through, the magnetic field gets
bigger, opposing the change in the current
flow and thus slowing its growth enough for
the alternating current (AC) to switch directions,
with it dropping to zero and going back up
in the opposite direction in the process.
Standard alternating current rates are usually
60 Hz a.k.a. 60 cycles per second (such as
in the United States) or 50 Hz (such as in
the U.K.).
Aptly named, for half of an AC cycle, the
current's charge moves in one direction, and
for the second half, the charge moves in the
other.
All of this switching back and forth further
affects the ballast's electromagnetic field,
since each time the current switches direction
(every half cycle), the polarity of the magnet
also switches; so, since the electromagnet
is fluctuating at twice the frequency of the
AC current, its flicker rate is at 100 Hz
or 120 Hz, depending on what country you're
in.
During these fluctuates in magnetic field,
the ballast's core is physically squeezed
and released in a process called magnetostriction
that, at a frequency of either 100 Hz or 120
Hz, produces the infamous buzz.
Of course, not all fluorescent bulb fixtures'
buzzes are alike, and this is due to differences
in the fixture's ballast type, size, how the
ballast is mounted, fixture design and the
degree to which the ceilings, walls, sheet
metal, etc. muffle or amplify the sound.
Such a common nuisance, the industry publishes
"sound ratings" for ballasts, and even recommends
in which settings different ratings are appropriate.
For example, those ballasts with an "A" rating
are the quietest (20-24 decibels), and they
are recommended for libraries, churches, reception
areas and in TV and radio stations, while
only a "C" level (31-36 decibels) is recommended
for a "general office area," and retail stores
can get by with "D" ratings (37-42 decibels).
For those who hate the buzzing (or perhaps
have issues with migraine headaches being
induced by the fluorescent bulbs and their
flickering light), electronic ballast (as
opposed to the old school magnetic ones) are
available and are even quite common today,
such as generally found in Compact Fluorescent
bulbs (CFLs).
These ballasts typically operate at a drastically
higher rate than 100 Hz or 120 Hz, usually
in excess
of 20,000 Hz.